I'm going to show you how to do question
six you do need to know how to do
through the calculator but you also need
to know how to do these in your head and
we'll check them with your calculator
okay
so have a look at this remove 1/2 plus
1/3 that's where we'll stop okay now I
want you to picture these guys are kind
of like trying to have a conversation
with each other right but it doesn't
work at the moment anyway because
they've got their common ground this is
gonna make them nothing to talk about
together okay this guy's all about twos
this guy's all that threes they don't
have anything they can actually share in
common okay now what we want is a common
thread of conversation a common
denominator right so that'll let the two
fractions work together which by the way
that's why when people can't talk them
anything they talk about the word up
because the only thing that everyone has
in common they're like it's what people
talk about when they got nothing else in
common okay we want to come in
denominator now let me just move this
over a little bit so I'm trying to add
these together okay now the great thing
about this is just like with the mixed
fractions we were doing before you can
multiply these fractions by anything
you'd like so long as you don't actually
change them this is what I need okay see
how you got to here and a 3 here ok so
to make this in common with the 3 I'm
going to multiply it by 3 over 3 stay
with me you're like why would you do
that it's gonna give me a common
denominator in a second the same thing
over here I'm gonna multiply by 2 over 2
okay yes where am I I'm choosing these
numbers so you can see the common
denominators going to pop out in a
second one right now when you multiply
fractions how does it work
you just got numerators and numerators
and denominators with denominators okay
so here I'm gonna get 3 times on which
is 3 right over what
and over here I'm gonna get 1 times 2
which is 2 over 6 yeah and now these
guys have a common denominator so bacon
here together 3 plus 2 of course is
there you go ok so that's how you do
your question yes yes yes that is
exactly the freshman now it's a good
question because it's like you know why
I have a multiplied Miss why not just
multiply this by 3 and we'll focus but
today I'll tell you why if I just
multiply it for instance let's rewrite
this question there was a 1/2 plus now
just suppose I'm like I want this to be
a 6 so I'll multiply that by 3 and I
want this to be a 6 as well so I
multiply by 2 now here's what I've done
when I multiplied the bottom but not the
top it's not the same fraction anymore
but this is not a half any longer it's
it's a 6 and so is this right that's
also assist there not a 1/2 and 1/3
which is what they started out as ok so
the way I get away from that that
problem is if you multiply the top and
the bottom you're not changing the
fraction right I'm on the top the bottom
here it's still a third and that's still
hard
it's just I'm writing it differently I'm
writing it's 3 over 6 and 2 over 6
okay so that's why I'm multiplying x-303
and 2 over 2 because that's why my 1
doesn't change the number okay now when
you have a look at this this is kind of
pulling together on one of the different
skills to be looking at in this little
exercise right first I'm gonna have to
convert these guys right 1 and 3/5 2/5
what's that
- I think that's five fifths plus
three-fifths
he's an S that one at the front well I
think that's it now I can put my
fractions together okay
times five and we're not for bonus
points because it was given to us in
mixed fractions can we put it back in
mixed fractions how many times just 20
go in replay
so it's the ring